je vais te raconter
comment j'ai rencontré ton père
c'était difficile de vivre le moment
présent 2022 il y avait toujours un
autre endroit où aller une autre
personne a rencontré je sais que ça peut
avoir l'air dingue mais j'ai eu 87
rendez vous sur kindle cette année mon
dernier rendez vous était fier de tous
il était un autre rendez-vous avant ça
les jeux vient de m'envoyer en l'air il
a dit ça comment il ose dire sort
vainqueur c'est même pas le pire à cette
soirée avec des nouveaux at il meilleur
endroit du monde répète après moi
aujourd'hui c'est le premier chapitre de
ma prochaine grande histoire d'amour
aujourd'hui c'est le premier chapitre
des marocaines grande histoire vous
devez rentrer avec charlie tout est fini
chap triste châtrices drapeau du
portugal a atteint je voulais mettre un
autre chatterie
temps fou de la maturité were on peut
encore faire de mauvais choix pendant
quelques années cette foire il a été la
meilleure de tapas le jour où tu
raconteras cette histoire surtout
promets moi de changer cette partie
nous vivons une époque très compliqué à
l'étude à tuer complètement dingue
et franchement j'adore c'est difficile
de rencontrer une personne et se sentir
connectés que sa part est facile il faut
qu'on se remette sur le marché va lui
parler et je lui dis quoi je crois que
je vais te plaire joliment alors
tous les deux on va prendre cette ville
à bras le corps parce qu'on n'a pas peur
de toi new york on est des personnes les
plus courageuses de la ville
je vais boire à ça
[Musique]